hello citizens of the reject Nation it's me
Tara Erickson alongside what is your name
again Greg oh God what's the last name though
Albertsons that's all I gotta think of today
we are watching The SpongeBob Movie have you
seen it of course not I haven't even seen
the show me neither same page I wonder if
it's going to rain too drastically affect
our Beauty experience we were both just sitting
here silently not laughing I don't get any
of this is this gonna be all inside jokes
that we don't get I think it's going to be
a fun experience they make a movie they gotta
make it somewhat adjustable for those who
haven't seen the show right all right well
we're diving in you guys so please don't forget
to leave a like and a comment and also ring
the bell
Bell when you subscribe because you're definitely
gonna subscribe and don't forget that if you
guys are a patreon on patreon you get to watch
the full length reaction and watch along with
us with me and gray like we watch the whole
thing you sit there and you're like wow it's
like you're watching at home with us it's
a cool experience so get on top of that if
you're not already a patron and now I say
super sexy something oh you were so perfect
up until so perfect it was like every time
someone's handed the intro they're always
butchering I was like Tara's doing better
than everyone oh no dude it's rolling just
roll the roll the real rejects intro Roll
It Roll It and Roll the clip
[Music]
what are you confused by the seagulls Craig
what was it what no I thought it was like
a animated movie
gotta love me some Pirates
[Applause] gold I never thought I'd see it
in the own eyes [Music] oh
I was actually really invested in that intro
it's probably really effective in a movie
theater
and it sounds different in the show [Music]
yeah go to the theaters you freaks [Applause]
I think no one sat on those front two roads
yeah those are the worst roads to sit in back
row is where it's at aisle seat A Story begins
in bikini bottoms popular undersea Eatery
the Crusty Krab restaurant Krusty Krab [Applause]
[Music]
thank you oh geez
get a hold of yourself Eugene I'm going in
I'm the manager of this establishment everything's
gonna be just mine I'm really scared here
man you got a name still you got a family
Phil I want you to do me a favor Phil say
cheese [Music] oh my God that's so dumb I
love it [Music] order up [Applause]
[Music] [Applause] it was all a dream today
is the grand opening ceremony for the Krusty
Krab 2 where Mr Krabs will announce the new
manager this is not gonna go the way you want
well let's ask my wall of 374 consecutive
employee of the month of War nice
oh big bathroom I want that bathroom oh okay
all right
it's actually pretty inventive yeah I support
that
no that's awesome oh
it's scary
oh my gosh this reminds you like Mr Bean that's
me in the shower [Music]
that's Greg and John in the shower I could
say I'll be thanking you in my managerial
acceptance speech today
tonight after my big promotion we're gonna
party party to purple
[Music] [Laughter]
this is so hyper goofy goober yeah
please tell me there's Goofy Goober ice cream
somewhere crab restaurant for years the only
place to get a delicious and mouth-watering
crabby patty that is a great animated looking
Burger long time owner Mr Krabs opening a
new restaurant called the Krusty Krab 2. exactly
oh my God right next door hello
crab right next door to the original Money
capitalism crabs is being interviewed by perch
Perkins and I've never even had one [Music]
well it might just be the marketing buddy
I just mopped the floors who carried my computer
wife the secret to crab success the formula
for the Krabby Patties that people would line
up to eat at my restaurant there are some
high stakes here I've exhausted every evil
plan in my filing cabinet from a to y the
letter after why
[Music]
that was clever and I will rule the world
oh hell plated
[Laughter] oh I think I stepped in something
no now before we begin with the ribbon cutting
I'd like to announce the name of our new manager
who's it gonna be is it gonna be the squid
[Applause] [Music]
I knew it
[Music]
that's like that Oscar upset with La La Land
This is like Zoolander you didn't get the
job what why you want to employee of the month
like all the time 365 days a million million
times he's more uh I'm not mature I mean this
in the nicest of ways character are coming
in but there's a word for what you are and
that word is uh Ding-A-Ling nuts expensive
big spasitron and to be a manager you have
to be a man you understand I guess so Mr Krabs
just open up your own Burger Joint but is
he mature enough to do that
there's adult humor in this poor squid didn't
get a party I get the world yeah I get the
world I don't need to watch a whole show multiple
Seasons
you have confessed to the crime of touching
the king's crowd but it's my job your highness
I'm the Royal Crown polisher
oh my goodness and the dungeon it is you're
free to go bless you princess Mindy what a
good princess I wish you'd try a little love
and compassion instead of these harsh punishments
that would be nice the Draconian way of rule
is not the way to go this Crown entitles the
one who wears it to be in charge of the sea
wear it until you learn how to rule with an
iron fist like your father [Music] your crown
what the [Music] oh that's no good you cannot
rule a sea without a crown but the crown is
useless without a king I don't know I feel
like the crown does it all hey goobers I want
to go to here this place looks amazing oh
I'm a goofy goober yeah oh my God that's a
survey [Applause] the nut bar get it together
oh boy I know I'll just stop thinking about
it that's called denial I usually feel a little
better I don't even remember why I was sad
hey it's the new Krusty Krab 2 manager you
didn't get them no he just set the place on
fire and ran away asking if they saw his butt
me with most desserts I'm feeling better
this is too much
I was not prepared for how kinetic this would
be get up yeah hey come on buddy I want to
go home come on pal oh my goodness oh whoa
does he also have pink eye he looks like so
hungover good morning go scrape up your friend
and get going
um
work that doesn't respect you aim crabs your
heinous
are you left one damning piece of evidence
at the scene I stole your crown [Music]
oh man
that was the master plan before I turn this
conniving crustacean into fish meal who here
has anything to say about Eugene Krabs I got
something oh no I love this oh my God yes
please Kingdom
I
now realize that he's a great big jerk I deserve
that manager's job anyone else no well then
you gotta have an alibi man how could you
not have an alibi
[Applause]
[Music] hey you sobered up very quickly Mike
Crown is a symbol of my king-like authority
and uh between you and me my hair is thinning
a bit so I'm sure it's not that noticeable
oh my God he's so wild if I went to get your
crown back no one who's gone to Shell city
has ever returned you're just a kid he's a
sponge he's willing to risk his life to find
your crown and save his boss but daughter
I please father oh my God that's Scarlett
Johansson's voice it doesn't take that long
to figure it out be back here with my crown
in exactly 10 days you can do it in nine eight
seven six what are you doing until then the
crabtale remain Frozen where he now wait
ing oh turn on the AC Mr Krabs you didn't
hear any of this there's a giant Cyclops who
guards the outskirts of the city and preys
on innocent sea creatures don't let him catch
you because if he does he'll take you back
oh my gosh he's so excited take this what's
in here the magical bag of winds open the
bag of wins and you'll be blown back home
I'm coming there's such a frenetic energy
about this you've got nothing to worry about
your life is in our hands [Music]
hardcore relied on this is a visual comedy
it is it's really really impressive
good like the coffee is so much of the editing
too oh yeah it's great they do a really good
job of pacing in this movie oh no that's amazing
on a Paddy Wagon steel belted pickles
rejected french fryer with dual overhead grease
traps oh my God if you could get an airplane
this should be a real real Park that'd be
great what I like to run around but I've got
crabby patties to make over at the chub bucket
oh I will say that the Chum Bucket is very
dirty and I wouldn't eat a sandwich there
he's such a diabolical genius why is he trying
to run a restaurant yeah he should be like
stealing creatures under the sea and like
stashing them in the Chum Bucket do I need
to watch a whole show to understand we're
off to get King Neptune's Crown in Shell City
Lord take off your hat and respect respect
for the day dance
over the county line oh yeah we'll see about
that out of the car fellas uh oh oh no man
barely had it such a cool Paddy Wagon oh wow
he cleaned it up at least
[Music] die out music is a nice touch
indicate that
they're going after the crown I've already
hired someone to take care of those two dead
Dennis I'll kill you I'll kill you fool [Music]
evidence
[Music]
that's violent do they never talk again oh
that's no good oh my goodness
we must be close by now this is like Reese
Witherspoon in that one movie where she has
to hike a lot
okay SpongeBob look our car
[Music] these cutaways man they're really
good at that oh there it is the key how are
we gonna get it I get HP Lovecraft beat him
in pool everybody's attention I have to use
the bathroom right over there
stupid contacts oh my goodness it's a face
[Music] you should be getting keys and driving
but you know what I support this bubble party
it looks like a lot of fun they're trying
to say they're just kids but I'm pretty sure
they suffer with the Attention Deficit Hyperactive
Disorder right yes
[Music] oh my God no time for the test no
baby can resist singing along to this Patrick
uh don't do it don't sing to it I'll turn
it up louder [Music] oh that's so great I'm
a goofy goober yeah
[Music] [Laughter]
what oh saved by the Siamese twins looks like
we got a
you can't survive that what is the commentary
on beating up Siamese people that they're
doing here at least they got the key well
I got it at the Chum Bucket Plankton's giving
them away free with every Krabby Patty is
there some type of mind control thing you
may have put Wings everyone else in this fat
Watertown but you can't fool me I listen to
Public Radio he's an NPR guy you set up Mr
Krabs you stole the crown so Neptune would
freeze him and you could finally get your
stubby little paws on the Krabby Patty formula
ah he gotcha but you made one fatal mistake
you messed with my paycheck
now activating helmet brain controlled oh
you called it yes okay all right Chum Bucket
you have to really rely on everyone really
obsessively wearing these yeah yeah like do
they not take them off what okay
whoa
how do they see there's no way out
the world's getting kind of bumpy here
hey look free ice cream [Applause] [Music]
it's a setup it's a trap wait a minute [Music]
[Laughter] okay Patrick
I said Let go please oh
are you
are they in a mouth [Applause] holy junk [Music]
can't be that sharp [Music] well he just blew
a bubble so
much WoW one punch
that's pretty far oh right in the tug boat
no more boat okay [Music]
wow Circle of Life horrors of the trenches
where's the road this is where we find out
if they can swim oh boy hey SpongeBob look
here's the way down oh well we're not gonna
get the ground standing here on to Shell City
the stairs talk I'm going home Patrick but
what about Mr Krabs we'll never survive in
that trench this is man's country but you're
gonna die either way show us your man and
go down in that scary trench pull your pants
up Patrick we're going home but you can't
go home I knew it oh Mindy is her name I heard
enough did you see my underwear no Patrick
did you want to ah Patrick no or should I
say blank topless what is this a magic mirror
this Monument is celebrating my glory is it
gonna build itself move faster Anarchy Squidward
oh no even Gary oh but we're just hey it doesn't
matter if you're kids and what's so wrong
with being a kid anyway Kids Rule yeah I mean
kind of I mean keeping their child likes in
you is the thing that Sparks imagination and
creativity
why I guess I'll just have to turn you into
men good old reverse psychology with my Mermaid
Magic
but because they're so childlike they'll be
able to convince themselves yeah they're susceptible
to it I'm with you on that they're very malleable
oh my God
so now that you're men can you make it to
Shell City oh I don't think it's working as
well as she thought it would
[Applause] [Music] [Applause]
why did we jump over the edge instead of taking
the stairs because we're Invincible ah oh
it's good nice men land we're safe and sound
at the bottom of this trench oh consistent
visual gags man Now That We're Men we can
do anything
[Music]
you know what this feels psychedelic yeah
I was like do people get high and then watch
SpongeBob yeah it feels very trippy
[Music]
oh my gosh they have an army now
[Music] [Applause]
you lost your army because you were a meanie
are they sure the crowns in Shell City could
have just been a mislead I've been ironed
my friend here in a good mood today so I'm
gonna let you off with a warning awesome Wrath
of our mustaches [Music] oh no this tennis
is a Dream Crusher man Plankton was very specific
wanna meet a stick find out that he stole
the crown wow this guy's revealing everything
perhaps I've said too much you sure have Dennis
these are sharp kind of cool boots I'd be
into wearing those
oh [Music] that's cool awesome that's really
clever that's Cyclops to come around like
that
what where does he take these why does he
want them yeah that's what I'm saying is he
gonna do like a science experiment he's he's
a marine biologist he's not hooked up to anything
how does he get back to the surface great
question artificially colored rocks [Applause]
oh no they're in a tank
yeah I'll go like we see buddy [Music] yep
yep those fish are dead dead
man aren't you on isn't it kind of hard to
breathe in that helmet uh
[Music]
it's good okay he's full-on sociopath you
think so oh no oh no their perspective on
this lamp tell me about it there's like some
weird body horror stuff in this I don't even
think we're gonna be able to save ourselves
buddy oh this is disturbing at least they
die together we never made it to Shell City
Shell City [Music] and so Shell city is a
gift shop but if this is Shell City then where's
the crown
[Music]
[Music] this is horrifying oh boy oh the tears
can loosen them up oh
[Music] oh my gosh the music I can't imagine
watching this in the theater I'm being a child
dude like what is happening oh no trippy
wow that tear can really move okay the chairs
do something but I didn't think he was gonna
do this oh it's like a defibrillator shock
em back to life nope okay but they're dried
out uh sprinklers okay all right get back
up to SpongeBob and Patrick come on
yay ready one how are they gonna oh foreign
[Music] oh yeah now they're all coming back
to life because of the agua is that what's
happening you're in trouble now Cyclops I
don't think that's what's happening no okay
someone just oh my charger right yeah
taste your own medicine man Point bag away
from home okay plant feet firmly on ground
step three remove string from bag releasing
the wins sure
what have you done now you're really gonna
be have to come a man and find your way back
home with the crown you gotta put in the work
the Bikini Bottom now I can take you there
no way oh man oh my God it's actually David
[Music] huh
[Applause] guess who's here [Music]
hopeful I'm like what dolphin now it's like
a boat oh
oh interesting what if we run now we'll never
stop yeah Patrick oh man [Music] I was happening
on David Hassell
Park nice now [Music] no gosh survive not
in his foot oh oh nice but we'll never be
able to float down in time
oh my goodness
the control
wow David Hasselhoff looking pretty good for
his age done no no not David a beautiful town
I knew you could do it
My Parade shall be quite dry under my umbrella
oh no oh my no [Music] um
I'm Evil Genius and you're just a kid you're
so mean it's really not nice under the sea
I made it to shelter
oh my gosh can singing get them out of mind
control
what [Music]
oh my God people definitely do drugs and see
this one this is the most unexpected thing
in the world
oh boy [Music] ah yes
nice that's pretty cool
hell yeah whoa cool
[Music] this is insane it's the wizard who
saved us out of my way fool stomp on him yay
Karma man may I say so you are a very lucky
fellow to have in your employees such a brave
faithful and heroic young lad he's a great
man hmm oh my goodness I'm on it
I'm sorry I ever doubted you that's a mistake
I won't make again make a manager I think
we all know who rightfully deserves to wear
that manager pin I couldn't agree more sir
oh my God Squidward's coming around for him
too it is the greatest day of my life [Music]
wow all right Journey okay is that what the
series is like because does it go into like
where you're like on a trip like a like a
trip
so
you follow John mulaney's career at all uh
kind of well John Mulaney was on drugs and
then he got sober and his latest standard
special deals a lot with him being sober for
the past year or whatever okay this kind of
Comedy feels like what it's like when John
Mulaney is probably on drugs there's a lot
of the sensibilities the the dialogue the
humor seem like a guy who's on a very specific
kind of drug s or acid right yeah or a little
bit of sniffy sniffy stuff yep so trying to
watch some stuff for kids but we've said enough
but yeah that is uh I was not prepared me
neither I did not realize that it really would
turn into certain parts where you if you've
been to Disneyland the end of the rides are
just like this the dark moments in this movie
here what is happening here oh is this like
some post oh no I literally just finished
watching The Little Mermaid live action movie
and now talked about it extensively then five
minutes later showed up while I was filming
that I did sort of five minutes unlocked the
door for me from his phone and then and then
we're like all right Tara let's watch SpongeBob
which is another Under the Sea experience
it was Scarlett Johansson that was Baldwin
is Dennis okay knew it and then I experienced
this which was a drastically different Under
the Sea experience and I had to learn I did
not know this is how SpongeBob SquarePants
Works me neither I mean it was it was fun
but I was also I feel like not prepared I
feel like I needed to be on a little something
right like there are some really funny moments
though there no no it's hilarious but I'm
saying like when it cuts into certain songs
in certain parts I feel like people are laughing
the entire time if you have a little help
well the comedy is non-stop that's what I
mean like 20 it never breeds fruits yeah do
you feel like that sometimes with that like
you get a little worn it's a little over it's
it's a little overwhelming like I can't laugh
that much yeah yeah right it's a little overwhelming
and then you become a little like um desensitized
to it because it just it keeps going it keeps
going it keeps going and then I don't often
say this word for anything it truly is random
there is no Rhyme or Reason to it nope and
the show if I'm not mistaken is 22 minutes
an episode okay this is under a little under
80. yeah it's a very different experience
than a 22 minute chakra right for sure yeah
I mean there were some Hilarious Moments pretty
much from beginning to end there was something
and it was doing wrong it's very creative
it feels like a writer's room full of people
who like take a little something something
and then they just spit out random ideas and
piece it together you know I was thinking
that when I was watching I was like this script
well how did it get approved it's not like
I mean it is the way that they put it all
together with these characters it works but
like on the page I was thinking like was nobody
like we should make this more like add in
more stuff or do more bait and switches but
I'm like oh with the character set it like
it works perfectly even though I haven't seen
I want to see what the Rotten Tomatoes score
is oh man I would love to know okay 68 approved
okay and the audience scores 78 percent it's
a really goofy and entertaining for both children
and their parents yeah okay surreal is a good
one for it surreal yeah this is surreal it
was trippy it was psychedelic yeah it was
um kinetic uh and there's I there there is
also there is a story at the end I can't say
there's no story I don't yeah um believe in
yourself but it doesn't it's been a while
since I've seen a movie where they they don't
even attempt to take anything seriously it's
kind of crazy like they don't take anything
seriously yeah I guess you're right about
that even even uh Mindy Mindy was kind of
the only one who was like even though it sounded
sometimes sarcastic when she would talk was
the the only one who was slightly serious
about like Dad stop all this killing and listen
to me she was the only sound one that was
like I'll help you do this um uh otherwise
everyone else was just like on a limb well
yeah I mean uh even in her scenes though it
was there was constantly like just I'm saying
there's not once one scene in here right is
there's something even if it's like they're
dying on the lamp thing like there's some
comedy happening at all times at all times
uh yeah it's a bit overwhelming and I feel
like I feel like SpongeBob's eyes right now
where I'm like whoa I was not prepared for
this yeah for this trip that we went on me
neither but it was there but it was constantly
have something though where every once in
a while I would be like that is freaking hysterical
I I agree with that I just couldn't laugh
the entire time I don't know that I necessarily
wanted to because it was all I was always
funny but like I was always like oh this is
fun I was always amused it was I mean admittedly
there would be times where I was a little
annoyed yeah only because like I don't know
SpongeBob and uh my brain was not ready for
this right and so once in a while I would
be annoyed but then I would suddenly be like
oh now I'm laughing yeah he has to grow on
you I feel like these the both of the characters
and the uh when it really grew on me when
I really was like oh okay I understand it
when he was drunk when he and he shows up
drunk he's like I'll tell you what's wrong
then I was like okay I get that that's very
very funny and now I understand the character
is a little bit better in that moment for
me I was surprised by how sometimes there
would be like some like true adult humor not
just like oh these are jokes adults would
get like no this is straight up like a lot
of just like crap humor yeah a little bit
vulgar yeah um you know like the the hymn
like hung over jokes or yeah that was that
was great yeah they had that moment it it
would it would fluctuate between um between
these moments and so yeah I think it's not
just adjusting the character but adjusting
to the style because the characters all representative
of the style yeah I like I like the Squidward
character I was like oh I feel like he he
would have helped balance out some of this
energy because he's like the one who lives
in the most reality yeah if he would have
been in it more right like been in Incorporated
in it um if he was on the journey with them
yeah or if he was like this manager job is
to is like too overwhelming for him so he
decides to go try and find them on the like
the oh after
what
folks have to leave
okay
okay all righty okay I thought something was
gonna happen there at the end you just slowly
slowly exit um oh and I also really like the
I I love I think there's a lot of great things
about the editing and the the way that it's
like smash the things that have just this
great visual comedy elements throughout like
the visual comedy can be really strong in
here for an anime if for animation instead
of like sometimes you watch these animated
movies that are gonna be annoying for people
where the comedy is really reliant on like
stupid pop culture jokes or whatever yeah
this is physical it's all physical yeah there's
there's almost something Leslie Nielsen about
it Leslie Nielsen me like Naked Gun meets
like a Family Guy meets like a Cartoon Network
show yeah yeah there's a lot of different
uh elements to it but it's like the smash
cuts to their reactions were really funny
it was mostly them being like silent yeah
and wide-eyed and they're like uh and that
that was like the one relief that I was like
that's very very that's funny and it's also
giving us one second where they're not constantly
talking or trying to like make us laugh I
guess with the dialogue yeah which was cool
yeah but uh SpongeBob grew on me over time
even Patrick who I thought was really frustrating
at first eventually became like he had some
really funny moments yeah uh overall yeah
I mean are we dead I liked when every time
he like he always had three words like are
we there like are we dead which I really enjoy
I would like to watch the first episode of
the show yeah all right okay yeah yeah yeah
like I bet you if you watch the whole series
these two guys really grow on you because
you have only 22 minutes you don't have to
like not have to but you're not sitting through
80 minutes of like an adventure with them
I think in short bursts these two will really
really grow on you well if you already seen
the show it says five stars at a 7.2 so clearly
the fans of the show like that they love it
yeah because if this um it was like I liked
it I can't say I loved it even though there
were some jokes that I absolutely loved um
because yeah people who wanted to watch the
show they already know they're already emotionally
they already are like the characters they
already love everyone yeah exactly and then
they're watching this then they're watching
the movie whereas I'm like cold man this is
an introduction like I've seen stuff of Squidward
in the past of like little things people have
posted and like I can't really tell you anything
about SpongeBob I've seen like things about
nothing that was like character defining traits
of him and and I was aware I've heard of Krusty
Krav I didn't know that it was a place that
SpongeBob worked at and I've heard the song
um so that was my familiarity is very limited
any of those things yeah go about it okay
yeah for this was uh it was like okay now
I understand some of these references I've
heard and then you didn't know anything no
so as newbies yeah this was our honest take
on it throughout honest hot take but um huh
any last words I'm brain fried right now this
is really it's really I want to talk so my
brain is fried I feel like I went through
shocking water I was like I need to keep my
eyes open and be registering everything they're
saying my eyes are really wide open right
now there's some really great visuals too
there's great visual Panache and I like like
Hasselhoff showing up I thought like that
oh that was great the commitment of it and
the creepiness and there was like body horror
elements to talk to the PEC smash that was
great there's something about the SpongeBob
world that reminds me of like I'm a big fan
I'm a fan of HP Lovecraft who a lot of his
world is like humanoid fish people and a lot
of that reminded me of this but like a parody
spoof version of it so that was fun that was
fun yeah
the review has been us trying to understand
what SpongeBob SquarePants have been like
what I feel like we just got here we're like
you guys what happened the hair is like it's
blasted back our eyes are wide open and red
and we're just shaking like we just watched
the SpongeBob movie and we knew nothing about
it going in that's us that was wild yeah you
guys will leave a comment let us know what
what you think what you thought if you've
watched all the episodes why we are terrible
people for not and um because we would love
to hear all about it um and what do I say
for the patrons uh if you could just send
it I need a shower or something now
yeah not not together and we'll see you guys
later that's it from us bye [Music] okay